- I have to bring this up
'cause I think it's funny.
- Okay.
- You were in another club.
I was in this club too, Girl Scouts.
You're a Brownie?
- I was kind of one.
- Okay, but I heard that
(chuckles) you got kicked out.
- Yeah, so I think when-
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughing)
- Who gets kicked out?
- Only the coolest people, obviously.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
Well, I was little,
so you're only like five or six
in Brownies.
- When you're brownies, yeah.
- And so I don't think
they officially call it
just kicked out,
they're not that hardcore.
- Hardcore.
You're just not welcome back. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- But me and my best friend,
Jamie Valentine, in Arizona,
I think we were just
being too rambunctious,
and I think the story on the street
is that they told our moms
that we weren't invited back.
- Oh, my gosh.
- We weren't Brownie material.
I don't know what to say.
We loved it.
- Aah.
- I hold it dear,
I think that's pretty cool.
- I got kicked outta
Sunday school once.
- What'd you do?
(audience laughs)
- Here's the thing.
My friend, Mary, whatever,
(Keri laughs)
my friend, Mary, and I, we,
I was like, I don't know
if I should say this,
but we were laughing at something else.
- It happens.
- In the Sunday school,
and you know, when you're a kid-
- And you can't stop.
- You just can't stop.
- Can't stop.
- In the Sunday school,
the teacher was very sensitive
in the first place.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And probably shouldn't have been
a youth leader in general.
- A youth leader, yeah.
(audience laughs)
- This was not her forte.
- No.
- And so we laughed,
and then we tried to stop.
Like, I'm so respectful,
but I could not stop laughing,
and then we got kicked out.
- It makes it worse.
- And then I was like, oh, my God,
who gets kicked out of
Sunday school? (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Cool people.
- Yeah.
- I was like, I know I felt bad.
I think about her to this day.
I feel bad about it,
but I, once you start
laughing, it's hard to stop.
- It's such a good release though.
- And then you-
- And those are so,
it's amazing.
- Exactly,
and then you're like,
you're laughing even more
'cause you're supposed to stop,
and you're a jerk.
You're in puberty.
- It's culture chaffing.
- You're already a jerk already.
- Yup.
- Like, it's, yeah,
it was not a good time.